The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons License.
Your support will help MIT Open
Courseware continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT Open Courseware at
ocw.mit.edu.
Hi.
I'm Brian.
We're going to be going over
problem number 13 of the fall
2009 final exam.
I like to think of the theme of
this problem as polymers.
So that's the overarching
concept.
But I'm going to give you some
things I think are important
to review and to know before
actually meaningfully
attempting this problem.
So there's three things that I
that I sort of thought were
very important.
The first one is polymerization
processes.
So we learned in class and in
the book as well that there's
two ways that we've covered that
you can create a polymer.
And that is through either
addition polymerization or
condensation polymerization.
And I'll talk about that
more in a second.
The second thing you want to
know is basically molecular
weight and how it applies
to polymers.
And you want to know about
elastomers for this problem.
If you don't know about
elastomers then you'll have
trouble with the last
part of the problem.
So that's kind of what
I would review.
And then once you've got that
under your belt give the
problem a try.
So we're going to go
and we're going to
start the problem now.
We're given in the problem the
6-aminohexanoic acid, which
I've drawn here.
And we're also given at the
beginning of the problem the
structure of nylon 6.
This is the actual reaction
that's used to create nylon.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to show you--
or ask the question of how
do we create nylon from
6-aminohexanoic acid.
And that's actually going to
answer part A and part B to
this problem.
So to create a polymer--
in this case we're talking about
the polymer nylon 6--
you actually have to add
together many mers.
So merge is the term we used
to denote the single unit
which is repeated n times
to create the poly mer--
polymer.
So in this case the mer, the
individual unit of nylon 6, is
6-aminohexanoic acid.
And that's this.
That's the same thing
right there.
So we're going to add these
together and we're going to
start creating our long
chain of nylon 6.
Remember, nylon 6 a polymer is
a really, really long chain.
Think of it as spaghetti,
very long spaghetti.
It isn't just two molecules
that react.
So let's just start somewhere.
It's got to begin somewhere.
You have to have two molecules
at some point in the beginning
reacting with each other.
So let's look at our
two molecules of
6-aminohexanoic acid--
I have to keep looking back
at how to say that--
so let's take a look and we have
to think about now our
two possible processes or routes
towards polymerization.
There's addition and there's
condensation.
Now addition, as you probably
read and heard, requires there
to be a double bond present
between two carbon atoms. The
reason for this is because
usually have a free radical
coming in, which will
then initiate.
That's why oftentimes the free
radical molecule or free
radical provider is called
the initiator.
You need an initiator to come
in to break that double bond
and then create another
free radical.
Which then lets the process
continue along in
a chain like that.
If we look at our molecule here,
we don't actually have
any double bonds between two
carbon atoms. We have a double
bond with an oxygen but that's
not sufficient for an
addition-type reaction.
For a condensation reaction,
what that basically implies is
two mer units, or two things
coming together to react and
they give off a byproduct.
So that's how I remember
condensation, very often the
byproduct is water.
You can have other byproducts,
like HCl or any other sort of
small molecules can
be given off.
But most times what we'll see
in 3091 will be water given
off in condensation, so it's
sort of intuitive to call it
condensation.
In this problem, if we look at
this, we have a molecule that
has the Hs on one side and has
Os on the other side, we can
actually almost see this
immediately as being a
condensation reaction.
What's going to happen is we're
going to have this O
reacting with the positive
end of this
molecule, which has Hs.
And we're going to have an H2O
liberated and given off.
We're going to have the
new molecule formed.
Let me draw the molecule
for you.
Let me write it out.
So we've just begun forming
our polymer and this is a
polymer which has an n of 2.
It has 2 mer units
building it.
Notice I've kept
the ends here.
The positive and the
negative here.
In reality what's going to
happen is we have a big vat of
this 6-aminohexanoic
acid and they're
going to keep reacting.
So we might have another one of
these molecules float over
and react with this O.
Or conversely, we could have
another one of these molecules
come over and react
with the H.
So this thing is going
to keep building.
And the way these polymerization
processes begin
is the control of some parameter
of the system.
It could be temperature,
pressure you can add something
in to sort of initiate it.
But that's how this
is going to start.
So we've actually sort of
answered part a and b.
We've come to the conclusion
that this is obviously a
condensation reaction.
Because we're going
to give off--
I left that out there, see
if you guys caught it--
H2O.
So we're losing this O and
two of these Hs and
we're forming water.
And that's the byproduct.
And a byproduct immediately
should tell you we've got
condensation going on.
So condensation polymerization,
part A.
Part B, we've actually already
done to sort of logic out the
answer to part A.
This is the answer to part B.
Part B is just the reaction.
I'll read it very
specifically.
Write the reaction that converts
two molecules of
6-aminohexanoic acid into
a dimer of nylon 6.
So we have two molecules
forming the dimer.
You are going to have trimer,
and it goes on and on.
The most common mistake on this
problem was to give us
the full repeating units.
Let me just show you what
that would look like.
And then we'll move on
with the problem.
So the most common mistake on
this problem was to not have
these end units.
And instead say, oh it's created
this huge, long chain.
So I'm going to write
it as follows.
And this is the symbol to
imply that it repeats.
Likewise over here.
So people would give us this.
And that's not correct.
And the reason that's a problem
is because not only do
you lose points on this
part, you also lose
points on the next part.
So part C is now asking us to
calculate the molecular weight
of a molecule given
a certain n.
n is the degree of
polymerization.
So in this case, n equals
2, we've got a dimer.
In part C, we have n equals--
surprisingly--
3,091 You'll see that's a
recurring theme in this class.
So we have n equals 3,091 And
the question is, how do we
approach the molecular
weight problem?
Well we're told that we have
3,091 one of these mer units
making up this polymer chain.
So let me just write
this down.
We're going to form
an equation.
If we take the mass of the full
chain and divide it by
the mass of a single mer unit
we should be able to extract
the number of units
in the chain.
So let me write that
out for you.
So the total molecular weight
of the molecule, divided by
the weight of a particular
mer unit.
OK so we're going to
put that as mer.
And so this is easy.
Let's first identify what
our mer unit is.
And this is why it was easy get
tripped up on this problem.
Because if you made a mistake
on the part B, you have
trouble on part C.
What is our mer unit?
So in our mer unit, what we're
talking about is a chain which
has 3,091 of these linked
pieces here.
So let's look at this.
What do we have?
Here's our mer unit.
Let me circle it.
We have 6 carbons.
We have 11 hydrogens,
1 nitrogen and 1
oxygen in this mer unit.
We're not going to take the
full, complete end unit.
We're not counting this O.
We're not counting those 2 Hs.
We're dropping off 18 grams
per reaction into water.
So this is our mere unit.
Let's calculate the mass
of our mer unit.
So it's going to be--
let me write this here--
we're looking for molecular
weight.
We're going to divide that by
the mass of the mer unit.
Let me just write out the full
line of what it would be.
Approximately 6 times
12 plus 11 times 1.
So this is 6 carbons, times
the mass of carbon.
11 hydrogens times the
mass of hydrogen.
We're going to have 1 oxygen
times the mass of oxygen.
And we're going to have
the nitrogen as well.
So let me add that down here.
1 nitrogen times the
mass of nitrogen.
I rounded.
That's OK.
As long as you get
the idea right.
So now we can easily
just solve for
the molecular weight.
And we'll find that molecular
weight in this problem will be
equal to 3.5 times 10 to the
fifth grams per mole.
There's another way to do
this problem, actually.
And what you can do is you
can calculate n times
the number of this--
this particular molecule--
and you can subtract
off 3,090 orders.
18 grams. 3,090 times
eighteen.
You subtract that off.
Think about a little bit why
it's 3,090 and not 3,091.
So that's just maybe a
brain teaser for you.
That is the answer to part C.
And now part D asks us if we're
able to convert this
into an elastomer.
So this is where it's really
required that you understand
what an elastomer is and what
that implies and what the
structure looks like.
So an elastomer--
and I sort of paraphrased this
from the book and added my own
thing to it-- is basically a
randomly oriented amorphous
polymer with some cross-linking
such that you
have the ability to move the
chains but not slide them
completely over each other.
So in order to have an elastomer
you must have
cross-linking.
In order to have cross-linking,
what must you have?
Well from lecture and from
the book we know that to
cross-link you must have double
bonds in your carbons.
So you must have 2 carbons--
going back over here--
which are double-bonded
together.
And why is that?
Because what happens is those
double bonds will be broken by
some initiator element-- many
times we'll have sulfur--
will come in, break the double
bond and then you'll have
links forming between things.
So let me actually give you
real-life example of this so
you can see what I'm
talking about.
We're going to show disulfide
bridges bounding and creating
cross-links in a molecule.
Something we're very familiar
with is rubber.
And we're also very familiar
with car tires.
The big difference between
those two things is that
rubber has vulcanized Which
means we're actually putting
sulphur into it to create a
different type of polymer.
We're looking at a cross-linked,
much stronger
rubber which we use
on our car tires.
So polyisoprene looks
something like this.
You should be familiar with
this notation by now.
We have this denotes
it repeats.
We have our double
bonds, we have
our carbons and hydrogens.
This is polyisoprene.
And this is what we're
going to add sulphur
to vulcanize rubber.
We're going to create
vulcanized rubber.
sulphur generally actually
looks, it's a ring of 8
sulphur atoms. We'll then
add it to rubber,
maybe heat it up mixed.
And you'll make what you're
used to on car tires.
So what's actually happening
here is that you can see we
have this double bond
between carbons.
The sulphur's going to come in,
it's going to react with
this double bond, and is
actually going to pull it off.
And it might form a
chain like that.
And then this sulfur will then
connect to another one of
these polyisoprene molecules
that was
originally double bonded.
And I'm not going to draw
the rest of it out.
And it's going to react, kill
this double bond, and it's
going to connect it.
So basically what's happened
in this process of forming
sulfide bridges is you've got
this polymer, polyisoprene,
connecting to this polymer,
polyisoprene, and you have
cross-linking going on.
And that's what we would need
to have in our case for the
nylon 6 in order to get an
elastomer, And because nylon
6, because our mer unit,
6-aminohexanoic acid doesn't
have double bonds, we
can't break them.
We can't network.
We can't cross-link.
And therefore we can't
make an elastomer.
So the answer to
this problem--
in a very long-winded manner--
is no.
You cannot create an elastomer
given that mer unit.